bonjour bonjour à tous mais je vais très
très bref est ce que je vais vous parler
de la méthode et puis on va débattre ce
matin et puis on parlera de la synthèse
tout à l'heure je voudrais d'abord dire
que le temps du projet elle est
aujourd'hui venu nous présentons ce
projet mais c'est pas un projet qu'on
découvre aujourd'hui ici 15 mois de
travail c'est une durée très longue
depuis la première convention jusqu'à
celle de cette semaine nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup travaillé beaucoup
publié et beaucoup débattu et vous avez
donc se tord du projet il est maintenant
venu et vous voterez tout à l'heure sur
ce projet vous êtes venus très nombreux
et je vous en remercie et vous avez
raison les présents d'une certaine
manière ont toujours raison et les
présents qui sont aujourd'hui prête à
débattre on encore plus raison d'être
d'être là selon débat c'est un débat qui
nous conduira à un moment donné à
l'élection présidentielle elle même est
au fond à l'alternance dont on rêve tous
et dont la france est évidemment besoin
et ce projet il prend part dans une
forme de chronologie une sorte de série
de temps de continuer n'y a pas de
rupture d'abord il ya le temps du parti
c'est ce que nous faisons avec nicolas
sarkozy
aujourd'hui ce temps du parti sultan du
jeu collectif et puis il y aura le temps
de la primaire un temps où le débat sera
encore plus vif ou la compétition sera
lente et où finalement sera sélectionné
celui ou celle qui nous représentera
lors de ce projet d'alternance et puis
il y aura le projet de l'élection
présidentielle y aura le temps de
l'élection présidentielle elle-même et
puis après après il y aura ce temps de
l'action ce temps de l'alternance est
c'est parce que le projet sera prêt
c'est parce que le projet sera fort
c'est parce que le projet sera dans les
esprits des français qu'il sera
évidemment possible de le mettre en
oeuvre vite et bien et ce débat c'est un
débat qu'on a conduit avec vous et je
voudrais d'abord vous indiquer que ce
débat il s'est fait en 18 journées 2
travail thématiques on a fait 18
conventions c'est tout à fait
considérable et vous avez le document
vous avez 350 pâle vous savez on nous
dit toujours il faut trois pages on en a
fait quand même 360 et il ya 360 pages
qui reprennent l'ensemble des
conventions qui ont été organisées
depuis maintenant 15 mois c'est donc
considérable et c'est aussi la meilleure
manière d'infuser de distiller de dire
les choses et de laisser à celles et
ceux qui veulent réagir sur ces choses
leur laisser le temps de le faire donc
18 journées de travail des u12 rendez
vous du projet qui était aussi des
débats organisée au siège et une 260
intervenantes sont qui ont parlé qui ont
pris la parole qui sont engagés pour
dire leur position et leur expertise
dans ces journées des chefs d'entreprise
des membres d'associations des élus
enfin beaucoup de monde et on a reçu
aussi beaucoup de contributions il 4600
contributions qui ont été reçues sur le
site ou dans les courriers divers
beaucoup de français ont beaucoup réagit
à l'idée d'un projet on envoyait
beaucoup d'idées sur beaucoup de sujets
je voudrais vraiment les en remercier il
leur dira que tout a été lui tout a été
lu beaucoup a été repris aussi dans ce
qu'ils nous ont dit et puis il ya eu les
votes le président nicolas sarkozy a
voulu que chaque convention se termine
par des votes que l'on consulte les
militants ces vols quand on prend
l'ensemble des votes cumulés ces trois
cent soixante mille votes après les
différentes conventions c'est donc le
fruit d'un débat profondément
démocratique est profondément me
semble-t-il
opportun au moment où on doit dire aux
français ce que nous voulons faire pour
pouvoir le faire après alors on est prêt
les républicains sont prêts le parti est
prêt le débat va se poursuivre nous
sommes prêts et nous sommes prêts comme
jamais nous n'avons jamais été aussi tôt
dans le débat dans la profondeur du
débat que
cette fois ci parce que la situation du
pays évidemment l'exigent mais ce sera
le sujet de la matinée et de cet après
midi je voudrais enfin dire que derrière
ce débat il ya aussi une volonté qui
s'exprime et une volonté très forte très
puissant de dire on a compris vous
français on a compris ce que vous nous
dites on a compris ce que vous souhaitez
c'est à dire un projet dans lesquelles
vous retrouvez à la fois de l'autorité
et de la liberté les cette belle liberté
d'entreprendre et cette autorité sans
laquelle rien n'est possible
place au débat maintenant
[Applaudissements]